it's 1500 GMT and we continue with
breaking news this hour Israel's
parliament has voted and approved to
change a crucial aspect of the country's
Judicial System the new law will limit
the power of Supreme Court judges the
controversial plan has led to mass
protests tens of thousands of Israelis
blocked roads outside the knesset to
demonstrate against the bill rallies
have been held since January when the
proposed amendments were announced
critics say the bill is a threat to
democracy
in a moment we'll speak to Bernard Smith
and Tel Aviv but first let's go live to
Laura Khan she's joining us live from
West Jerusalem tell us what's happening
there Laura
okay I'll just let you know where I am
I'm around 200 meters away from the
Supreme Court and also the Israeli
knesset where the reasonableness bill
was passed today uh I've been speaking
to numerous people in from the tens of
thousands of people behind me in the
protests people of course are angry
they're hurt they've been out protesting
for months not only against this bill
but also the full judicial overhaul
which was put on Ice just a few months
ago and many just didn't expect this to
go through or they certainly didn't want
it I just want to give you a sense of
what's Happening behind me this is a sea
of blue and white Israeli Flags people
have been out here in the blistering
heat for many hours at the head of the
movement it's actually put in one minute
after the after the reasonable business
bill was passed he put in a complaint to
the Supreme Court about this bill but it
puts them in a bit of a catch-22
situation because it's Supreme Court
could reject the bill but because of the
new bill they also can't so it creates a
bit of a constitutional crisis now here
to join me I actually have a member of
the reservist who's been one of the
leaders of the protest so thank you so
much for joining us can you just tell me
there are 10 000 reservists who said
they will not turn up to work if this
bill has passed
are you one of those will you not turn
up to work I'm one of those who also
volunteer but um first of all everyone
here
these amazing people behind me we the
people we have a personal uh story my
story is I'm also a disabled veteran so
I volunteer in other things and but the
mind the general mindset of course is
that this Minister this government of
Destruction are breaking the fundamental
contract between the country and the
model of our IDF which is the People's
Army an army by the people for the
people and therefore of course we want
that for volunteer we won't volunteer to
defend any country it's not about any
political
discussion it's not about right and left
it's about right and wrong and they ask
people that swear off only to the values
embedded in the Declaration of
Independence that we believe in Freedom
civil rights Justice and equality when
this contract is being broken we won't
serve the the country easy so is this
going to affect the stability and
security of a country that identifies
itself as an incredibly secure country
that where the military is one of the
most important aspects a brilliant
question we are not being interviewed to
a channel known as Al Jazeera so we I
guess that many of the public that
watching us right now I'm from Arabic
countries and they're very much curious
about the fact that Israel is a pivotal
country in the Middle East because of
the strength of the high-tech free
economy the IDF is is of course
is part of this great Innovation that us
Israelis have and the problem is that
the government current governments of
Destruction Israel destroying the
strength of Israel so of course the
consequences for that are very much
relevant for our International
relationship with Arab Nations and we're
here to stop the madness Israel has to
stay to stay a very strong major role
player in the Middle East and part of
the global Arena so from my perspective
yes it's very emotional point but we
believe that it's us the Patriots of
Israel
we're back again at the front line to
secure our Beloved Country and make sure
that Israel will remain a strong nation
in the Middle East thank you so much for
joining us back to you Nastasia
all right Laura thank you for that that
is uh Laura Khan live for us in West
Jerusalem let's go now to another
correspondent Bernard Smith and Bernard
tell us where you are and what's
happening there
so this is Central uh Tel Aviv live
where Liz where about an hour or so ago
not long after uh Parliament ratified
that law people came out now spontaneous
spontaneously to protest the police have
shut off access to a main Highway
because in previous protests here
protests have gone down there to shut
off sort of a main arterial Road through
the city they're not going to be able to
do that this evening there's a heavy
police presence but for 29 weeks
consecutively protesters have been
gathering in Tel Aviv against this
judicial overhaul it hasn't got them
anywhere the law has been passed and
there is an enormous frustration here
that this has happened but people have
come out of spontaneously to process all
right Bernard I believe it was uh on
Sunday yesterday that we saw people
coming out in support of these changes
too are there any rallies taking place
now in support of the bill that's been
passed
so you've got two types of you've got
Pro reform protesters and anti-reform
protesters now what you have here are
people who are against the reform
protesting for 29 weeks consecutively
they tend to come they tend to believe
that Israel which was founded by
generally Jews of European origin origin
was founded as a secular State for the
Jewish people but as a secular State
they believe that that is under threat
has been threatened by this overhaul but
what's happened perhaps in the least the
last 10 years or so is Israel has moved
further to the right this is more of a
liberal Island in what is a more
conservative country and the further
right the more conservative people which
generally tend to be ultra-orthodox Jews
more conservative Jews generally of
Middle Eastern origin they believe that
their demo that they have democratically
voted for these changes that their
Democratic wish is being uh uh stopped
by the Supreme Court and they have been
out protesting previously there aren't
out today they've got their way
essentially but there have been other
protests less of them though in favor of
these reforms all right Vernon thank you
very much for that that is Bernard Smith
bringing us the latest from Tel Aviv
thank you
well let's take a closer look at what's
been passed which is just one part of
the government's plan to change the
legal system the knesset has passed a
law preventing judges from striking down
the government decisions on the basis
that they are unreasonable Israel has no
written Constitution but the principle
has been interpreted by Scholars to
allow judges to review political
decisions based on public interest
critics of the new law say
reasonableness has been an essential
check and balance on the executive
branch of government that supporters of
the legislation say the reasonable
standard is too subjective and that it
interferes with decisions made by
elected officials
well let's bring in Marwan bashara he's
Al jazeera's senior political analyst
and he is joining us live from Paris
lots to talk about here madwan I want to
start with one thing that you've been
watching very closely and that's how
police have behaved with protesters
throughout the year there's been a
notable what there's a lack of violence
isn't there and is it notable do you
think given the size and the duration of
these protests
you know on the one hand it's I must say
it's to their credit
right six months of protest six months
of flooding the streets
and uh week after week we see tens
hundreds of thousands of Israelis and
the last day or two we've seen opposing
uh sides in the streets in the streets
of Jerusalem right thousands of opposing
camps uh protesting and we see the
Israeli security really even though they
would use some uh you know water hose
and whatever but in the end of the day
the degree of violence is so low that
really makes one I wonder two things
first of all why when uh say for example
in 2021 when few Palestinians in Israel
citizens of Israel went out and
protested in in Haifa and Jaffa and
other places
so much force so much violence was used
against them even pogroms in the likes
of Jaffa and so on and so forth while
against hundreds of thousands of Israeli
Jewish protesters there's hardly any
Violence by the security forces and
there's hardly any violence among the
protesters my analysis is the following
back in March if you remember and
perhaps it's good to remind our viewers
around the world prime minister
Netanyahu started speaking of Anarchy
when they were the first signs of
violence in Tel Aviv after protests
following the firing of the police chief
in the city by the security minister it
Martin real
because of his political positions right
since then there were some violence
there were few arrests like a dozen
arrests in Tel Aviv and suddenly the
entire country was paralyzed by fear
that this could in fact go out of hand
so since since March and even today
we've seen very soft handling the
protest because again my analysis is
with the first casualty
especially between the camps I think the
country is going down
to its dark side I think we're gonna see
Empire in the country yeah and on that
Marwan when you look at the size of the
protests and how much this judicial
overhaul has divided the country you're
right we've seen we haven't seen much
violence between police and protesters
but does it feel like a moment of
Reckoning for the country when you see
just how divided it is and what's at
stake here
foreign
Security Services the shimbate and
Shabbat and all of that they've been
looking at uh you know the social media
of the radical groups within the country
you know a group like La Familia right I
mean the name is already invokes uh you
know certain mafiosi type approached by
some fanatical right-wing groups that
follow that minister of security
something like the Jewish Defense League
in their social media uh encounters that
have been viewed by some journalists and
by the security services there has been
calls to use guns and knives and so on
and so forth against protesters just
again to remind our viewers around the
world those two fanatical ministers that
we have today in Israel like for example
the Minister of Finance he was arrested
he was kept for three weeks by the
security services
for attempting a plot of arson in Tel
Aviv so you have these very dangerous
elements both in power and in the
streets yeah and any one of them
carrying any major violent attack
against the opposing groups or against
any part of the city or the country I
think will lead to a major escalation
that I don't think even the security
services will be able to stop because
that's all remember
a big part of this country is armed to
the teeth and all of them have served in
the military and certainly when violence
take off in a place like Israel it can
really take off it is certainly a
worrying situation and one that we are
watching very closely that is our senior
political analyst Marwan Bashar alive in
Paris thank you Marwan